if you're looking to update your home
decor holy sheets
is sponsoring this next segment and has
something for every room in your house
starting with the bedroom
[Music]
there's one thing we all have in common
everybody watching right now and that is
we all need sleep and here at holy
sheets their goal is to give you the
best sleep possible i want you guys to
meet eric the owner how's it going buddy
i'm doing good how are you great so what
makes your sheets so special juicy feel
these
holy sheets that is soft that's why
people go nuts
and look at the colors we've got over 40
different colors
if you live in las vegas the bamboo
keeps at least 10 percent cooler than
cotton
and
also you get four cufflink pillowcases
so you have the sheets so comfortable so
soft but i also need a good pillow you
got pillows we've got the largest pillow
selection in the country show me let me
do it all right
holy [ __ ] eric you have a giant
collection of pillows yeah not only do
we carry the best sheets in town we also
got the largest pillow selection maybe
in the country it's amazing so what's
the pill we have right here this is a
convolution pillow my personal favorite
gives you the feel of a down pillow
the support of a memory foam that feels
really good this is another one we just
came out with
let's see how cool that is oh that's
real i love a cool pillow so what the
shoulder cutout does
side sleepers
give it a headlock
you're out for eight hours the mattress
though can i try this mattress you gotta
try it okay
holy sheets this is a comfortable
mattress tell me about i thank you it's
our own mattress we created it about
three years ago
10-year warranty
layered not only for coolness
comfort support and longevity it's very
firm i love the firmness and holy [ __ ]
you have so much going on in your store
can you show me more absolutely let's go
check it out holy sheets they have
massage chairs eric this is an
experience oh absolutely incredible
right yeah
tell me more my favorite part of the
store
not only can you come in
get an incredible
buying experience with all of our sleep
products
but you can also come in every time get
yourself a free massage in our media
room
you see the different selection each
time you come in you can try one
different eric your store really does
have everything it's incredible here
thank you so much we do a lot of custom
artwork we've got local artists in town
they bring their artwork in
uh original pieces we also do custom
acrylic work
uh all kinds of different light fixtures
love these tree plants
yeah we actually customize them any size
that you see here and i noticed when i
walked in here too you have a nice
little collection of dirt bikes and atvs
yes not only toys for adults but toys
for kids too well i think i think i'm
just saying i think the kids toys can
also be an adult toy as well i have one
one hole it starts i mean this is the
perfect way to end things i appreciate
it thank you absolutely thanks for
coming in and uh i gotta i gotta get out
of here but uh holy sheets they really
do have something for everyone here try
that baby out i'll see you guys later
and frankly i don't think jc got enough
play on the name holy sheets he should
have incorporated that more one more in
the story yeah holy sheets is at 98.93
southeastern avenue you can call that
phone number on your screen 565-4067
or go to
holysheetsusa.com and they have a
special offer buy one set of holy sheets
get one set free